Ben Shapiro who you work with at the
daily wire I think it's better to say
attacking you here's the video I just
want to get your reaction uh here is a
portion of Candice uh on Tucker Carlson
of Ben Shapiro who you work with at the
daily wire I think it's better to say
attacking you here's the video I just
want to get your reaction to the
question is about Candace ens I think
her behavior during this is been
disgraceful
without think she's been absolutely
disgraceful I think that her her F
sophistication on these particular
issues has been ridiculous everybody can
see the moves that she's making and the
things that she's saying and I findable
what is that about there there's nothing
that he has expressed in that at least
in that short clip that he fundamentally
disagrees with in terms of what I said
but I will say I'm not going to respond
with the same Ed hopin attacks I don't
think it helps further discussion and it
if I that was me that was caught on a
video saying that about colleagues that
I work with I would be embarrassed I
would so I think that the video speaks
more to Ben's character than it speaks
to mine has he texted you to apologize
or explain or anything no nothing I
haven't heard a single word it just was
sort of something that he said and you
know what Ben and I have many
disagreements so I don't think that
that's particularly something that's
interesting um we disagreed on the covid
vaccine we disagree on Ukraine and
Russia he has taken virtually every
stance that has been the opposite of
mine on every issue uh over the last
five years okay so I first just want to
reiterate something about the timing
this was all sort of planned so that the
Tucker thing was going to air with
maximum sort of chaos around it right
maximum verality around it which is why
she sent out that tweet and then Ben in
his own way you could criticize Ben and
say Ben you fell for it right you should
have just let it be she she quoted the
Bible clearly she was going after you
it's obvious she knows what she's doing
let's not pretend anything otherwise um
but but Ben did I suppose fall for it in
that sense and then again there are
these telegram channels that then they
post tweets and then they send all of
the most the worst possible things that
you could read about somebody they they
go after Ben probably more than anybody
else they're not thrilled with me either
um but part of this is also that this
this is sort of one of the things that
Candace likes to do and I don't even and
again Candace if you're watching this or
if your people are going to send this to
you later I'm actually not going after
you personally here this is we've gotten
into it a little bit on Twitter actually
even even two weeks ago or so related to
uh some of the Hamas stuff um but she
does like to fight with people on
Twitter she's done it with Megan Kelly
and with stepen Crowder and probably
even Trump and Des santis and Jeremy and
who and Ben and whoever like and with
rap stars and Kardashian I don't know
exactly but like it's part of like what
the thing is right um so Ben said that
she has faux sophistication when talking
about these issues I mean I think that
that is personally I think that that is
a fair issue we showed you the clip uh
what was it last Friday where she was
talking about the Muslim quarter in
Jerusalem as if Israel keeps Muslims in
a specific quarter Israel is the one
that has opened up Jerusalem to everyone
the quarters the Jewish quarter the
Muslim quarter The Armenian quarter have
existed for thousands and thousands of
years had Israel gone in and be been
like this quarter can't be Muslim
anymore we have to integrate it people
would have said the Israelis are racist
Chinese people live in Chinatown um so
she has had a level of FO sophistication
uh but it's also she says that he's not
criticizing what I say but I think a lot
of the criticizm criticism that's been
leveled at her has been it's what she
won't say like just flat out say that
Hamas is bad and
and all of the obvious stuff I think
that that's what some of the criticism
is